Tapping through the page,
it seems like focus jumps out of order
some where after these navigation links.
If I use document.activeElement, or if
I were to use the accessibility audit,
I can see that the item stealing
is a button with a class of close.
Looking at my source code, it appears
that there's some markup for a modal.
And sure enough, there's a button
with a class of close here.
Since I'm not currently
displaying this modal,
I'll update my CSS to set anything
with the class modal to display none.
That will opt it and all of its
children out of the tab order.
When I want to display the modal,
I can just override that style.